une fossé est assez grand entre ce que
propose le gouvernement même si alors
qu'il est on ne connaît pas encore le
projet de projet de budget mais on a
quelques quelques bribes d'informations
et ce que nous pourrions aussi non on
est on est les défauts qu'on dénonce
depuis 5 ans sont toujours là un recours
à cru à l'endettement ou parle de 5 % de
de PIB en déficit cette année encore sur
plus de 115 milliards 112 on parle d'une
augmentation de la dépense de la dépense
publique encore peut-être même une
accélération de l'augmentation de la
dépense publique alors que le mur de la
dette se rapproche 3000 milliards
d'euros de dettes nos voisins italiens
ont subi des attaques sur leur dette
souveraine de la part de edfun donc ce
mur de la dette il se rapproche et le
gouvernement continue d'accélérer ne
fait aucun effort de réduction de
maîtrise de la dépense publique donc ça
c'est un point de désaccord majeur qui
qui je pense condamne à l'échec des
discussions